Build It, Draw It, Play It.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build It.
Canadian artist Aganetha Dyck collaborates
with bees to alter man-made objects.
Honeybee Alterations takes things like porcelain
figurines in conjunction with the bees natural
beeswax making process to create altered sculptures.
And she uses the artwork to help illustrate
the delicate relationship between humans and
bees.
Daniel Rozin makes interactive mirrors out
of things like trash, fans, weaved material
and wooden pegs.
The sculptures react in real time to the movements
in front of them using custom software and
video sensors.
His installations have the ability to respond
to the specific presence of the viewer making
them part of the piece itself.
Michelle Jewell creates one of a kind stuffed
animals.
Body parts are made from fleece material with
unique clothing made from upcycled and vintage
fabric.
All of the toys are handsewn and stuffed.
Including plush fox friend, horse friend,
raccoon friend, and even a vermine friend.
Jeff Highsmith built his son this mission
control desk.
Featured on the MAKE YouTube channel, it has
a map and a magnetic backing to track the
spaceships route, a huge control panel of
LED lighted switches, and it recreates real-life
situations from actual NASA missions.
Such as when the crew of the Apollo 12 mission
was instructed to switch "SCE to AUX" after
a lightning strike.
Draw It.
Stones and Bones is a series by French Artist
DZO Oliver that uses bone and rock as a canvas.
When he was out of paper for a short time
he decided to use a different natural material
and says that the rough, smooth, and absorbent
surfaces made it quite the adventure.
Also, his paper illustrations are incredible.
Photographer Vesa Lehtimaki uses forced perspective,
baking soda, and lego to create scenes from
Star Wars.
The lighting, perspective and composition
make the photos incredibly realistic in never
before seen scenes from the movie like "Last
ship to rendezvous point", "The Backyard Falcon",
"Snow Troopers Delight", and "Casual Parking."
And now for the work of Bruce Yan depicting
iconic brands with a pop culture twist.
Joe Mangrum creates beautiful artwork using
sand.
He has created over 650 public sand paintings
worldwide since 2009.
He says the world is divided in so many ways
and he uses his artwork as spontaneous creations
in the streets to act as vibrant catalysts
for social interaction.
Play it
Using only empty bottles, Danish Group The
Bottle Boys play a mashup of classic hip hop.
Here is
BinkBeats performing a J. Dilla Live mixtape
for his Unraveled Project.
Squarepusher uses robots playing music to
create Z-Machines with a 78 finger guitar
and 22 drums.
Finally here is the official video for "Be
Around" by the Peach Kings created by Paul
Trillo.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTWO.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPis Radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys also
check out YOUR BiDiPi an entire video dedicated
to the creations of Vsauce fans and as always
- thanks for watching!